[Música]
bienvenidos a ella soy de france24
florida se convirtió en el estado más
grande de eeuu en prohibir a las mujeres
ya las niñas transgénero participar en
deportes universitarios y de secundaria
al menos 30 estados del país
norteamericano han hecho esfuerzos por
evitar la participación de las personas
trans en la rama deportiva y activistas
por la igualdad de derechos humanos
denuncian discriminación contra
argumentos de una ventaja natural mayor
para quienes nacieron con sexo masculino
es realmente el sexo de nacimiento una
ventaja a la hora de practicar deportes
y más aún es este realmente el centro de
la discusión cuando hablamos de niños y
niñas que quieren integrarse participar
y tener oportunidades en la sociedad
desde la identidad que eligieron vamos a
conversar del tema pero antes un resumen
de lo que pasó en florida
[Música]
en el primer día del mes del orgullo gay
el gobernador republicano ron de santis
firmó un proyecto de ley que prohíbe las
niñas transgénero inscribirse en
prácticas deportivas femeninas un
afrenta para la minoría diversa
les puedo decir esto en florida las
niñas van a jugar deportes de niñas y
los niños van a jugar deportes de minas
la firma se dio durante un evento en una
escuela cristiana en jacksonville con la
presencia de varias atletas adolescentes
de santis aseguró que la ley era
necesaria para garantizar la equidad
para las mujeres que participaban en
deportes en todo el estado poder
aprovechamos a proteger la equidad en
los deportes femeninos creemos que es
importante tener integridad en la
competencia y creemos que es importante
que puedan competir en igualdad de
condiciones los partidarios de esta ley
dicen que las atletas transgénero tienen
una ventaja injusta ya que fueron
designadas como hombres al nacer
argumentó objetado por los demócratas y
por los defensores de los derechos
civiles que califican la prohibición de
los deportes de niñas y mujeres
transgénero como innecesaria y
discriminatoria y acusan a los
republicanos de presentarlas como una
provocación
la ong human rights campaign anunció que
la demandaría penalmente pues la
legislación se dio bajo una premisa
falsa y discriminatoria que amenazaba el
bienestar de los niños transgénero
alabama arkansas misisipí montana
tennessee y west virginia aprobaron una
legislación similar y el gobernador de
dakota del sur firmó una orden ejecutiva
que respaldó la prohibición todos los
estados en lista son republicanos
vamos a conversar sobre las
implicaciones de esta legislación no
solamente para la actividad deportiva
sino también para los derechos humanos y
es que este golpe contra las minorías
diversas sucede precisamente en el
inicio del mes del orgullo gay están con
nosotros la peruana ariana lince
presidenta y fundadora de la ong ariana
center' y también el puertorriqueño
alejandro acosta activista por los
derechos humanos de la comunidad lgtb
y docente en educación sexual ambos
conectados desde la florida gracias a
ustedes por estar con nosotros y
alejandro voy a comenzar preguntándole
de una vez el principal argumento de
esta ley en florida es una supuesta
equidad deportiva que tan cierto es que
las personas que nacieron con un sexo
distinto a la identidad de género que
les identifica tienen una ventaja que es
lo que pasó hormonalmente y que ejemplos
nos puede dar
ese es parte del problema que esto nunca
había sido un hecho público esto no es
un problema que sea recurrente nunca
hayamos escuchado de niñas trans siendo
ventajosas en el deporte hasta que estas
leyes comenzaron a ser implementadas a
través del sur de los eeuu y como bien
ustedes dijeron estas leyes son
altamente republicanas
esto es él está él es el gobierno no
solamente infringiendo en los derechos
humanos pero también utilizando a la
comunidad el gp en este caso a las
personas transgénero como una ficha de
ajedrez para ganar
político esto es interés político y
arianna desde su perspectiva como una
mujer que ha tenido que luchar para que
sus derechos sean válidos siendo mujer
no solamente por el sexo con el que se
le identificó cuando nació usted ve que
existe una ventaja física en la práctica
de los deportes
no yo creo principalmente que esto es
una 30 y algo que el gobernador de
santis está discriminando a las mujeres
transgénero verdad dicho sea de paso
también ya la asociación y el comité
olímpico han mencionado la integración
de atletas mujeres o transgéneros en los
deportes porque es basado a la
testosterona y nosotras cuando iniciamos
un tratamiento de testosterona de
hormonas las testosterona no son las
mismas entonces yo creo que sí debería
existir una conversación lógica porque a
cualquiera le puede pasar verdad el no
saber o el no interpretar a una persona
transgénero pero creo que esta es una
una llamada del señor de santis porque
él quiere postular a cargos públicos y
después de la administración
la anterior administración que vieron
que había mucho mucha demanda para
personas
que discriminaban a nuestra comunidad
pues se le está tomando ventaja y por
eso lo hizo después de 24 años en el
estado de la florida no se hace una de
estas leyes tan discriminatorias para
comunidades vulnerables y vulneradas acá
en el estado de la florida y eso es
totalmente terrible muchísimas gracias
que ustedes ya hablaron que nosotros
como organización estamos trabajando
arduamente de la mano con el chelsea
para demandar contra demandar y que esto
se aclare en la corte suprema en otra
corte donde el 2 se nos dé los derechos
que nosotros necesitamos alejandro usted
es defensor de los derechos humanos y
además es educador en educación sexual
porque esto va más allá de un tema
físico por un lado el gobernador de
sancti se dijo que las niñas tienen que
jugar a un lado los niños tienen que
jugar al otro y por otro lado les
estamos diciendo a las ciudadanas trans
que si se integran en la sociedad pero
en deportes no en la utilización de
ciertos espacios no
y no puede ser que una ciudadanía sea
reconocida a medias
es parte del problema que están
discriminando inclusive dentro de la
comunidad trans porque esta ley es
solamente para niñas trans no está
contando a los niños trans y esa es ese
es a ser ese pensamiento de que hay
solamente deportes o actividades que
sean específicas para un género
pertenecen al siglo pasado ya no no
tienen espacio en este como usted bien
dice en este en este espacio que estamos
tratando de integrar a todo el mundo
como igual en la sociedad
inclusive discriminación pasa en todos
lugares cuando tiene que ver con el
miedo y lo que tiene el gobernador de
santi 6 de miedo de la comunidad trans a
comunidad el eje en florida y arianna
algo que yo veo que es aún más
preocupante es que esto es una decisión
que impacta directamente a la infancia
son niños y niñas que no podrán
desarrollar sus capacidades físicas que
no tendrán acceso a una gran fuente de
salud física y emocional y que están
viviendo discriminación desde el colegio
desde que son pequeños y están
intentando aceptar todos los cambios
físicos naturales y elegidos que vienen
para su cuerpo y que vienen para su
interacción con las demás personas
exactamente es tan tan desgraciadamente
es la gente que le quiere dañar toda la
vida
a unas niñas a unos niños verdad es
totalmente erróneo la ley implantada acá
en el en el estado de la florida porque
es republicano pero realmente pues es
algo que le va a impactar a muchas a
muchos niños ya muchas niñas del resto
de su vida
yo como peruana así como mujer
abiertamente transgénero orgullosamente
transgénero
soy el vivo ejemplo de lo que un país es
rechazar cuando tú eres transgénero y
otro país con las manos abiertas y con
el sistema
de mente abierta es yo acá tengo una
organización soy área anal y soy ariana
centre pero también en mi país sigo
teniendo la misma identidad de género
que anteriormente es más yo estudié con
el candidato a la vicepresidencia de la
república y las historias son diferentes
entonces estas leyes actualmente y
cuando la mencionó el gobernador dijo
los niños van a jugar con los niños y
las niñas van a jugar con
s esa idea tan en rodilla y tan arcaica
nunca nunca ha llegado a largo y como
les digo y les digo a todos ustedes
nuestra comunidad transgénero y la
comunidad de gente juntamente con como
activistas como como alejandro estamos
trabajando arduamente para que esta ley
sea quitada lo más antes posible y es
que sería un retroceso para los derechos
humanos alejandro desde su cátedra por
favor cuéntenos y para nuestros
televidentes porque es importante
entender la identidad de una persona más
allá del sexo con el que fue
identificado o identificada cuando nació
es interesante ver como los republicanos
se concentran tanto en los genitales
porque también por ejemplo tenemos un
sector de la comunidad que es intersexo
que realmente nacen no con diferentes
variaciones hormonales o físicas y están
bien los impactaría a ellos de una
manera adversa como parte de la leyes y
someterse a exámenes de adn o exámenes
para confirmación de género como es
posible que en el año 21 estemos
tratando de d
básicamente romper la privacidad y
tratar en niños por estos son niños y
niñas cursantes que no tienen necesidad
de estar pasando a personas muchos
destornillados también pensando en el lo
que quieren ser espacio de la comunidad
etc de sentirse incluidos y como y como
todos los demás entonces es ejemplo
interesante como esta ley infringe en
los derechos humanos de una manera
arcaica y también yo diría hasta
agresiva
estar verificando los genitales o hubo
pruebas de adn para
es realmente lo que da miedo también de
sant y las tienen y le tiene media
comunidad no solo le tenemos miedo a
personas como él que tienen el poder y
lamentablemente lo utilizan de una
manera errónea para hacer daño en vez de
para inclusión y la mental también
porque de santis es un padre y yo espero
que los niños desde santiago a esas
familias del no tengan nunca problemas
de identidad o por el mar o que se
sientan como si fueran personas de
agenda porque van a ser unas personas
muy infelices porque tienen un padre que
es la mentalmente discriminatorio y en
este caso yo diría agresivo contra una
comunidad que no ha hecho absolutamente
nada solamente aportar cosas positivas
al estado de la florida pues muchísimas
gracias a los dos por las impresiones
que nos entregan y en este mes es del
orgullo gay pues lo que haremos es
enfocarnos en lo importante que es el
respeto a los derechos humanos para
todos los ciudadanos y las ciudadanas
por igual sigan con nosotros en france
24 nos vemos próximamente en ellas hoy
[Música]